time out
i'm gonna have to bust a little move
when i'm hopping honey's down near the
spot
work some magic get some questions
hello oh hello hi how are you fine
so do you ladies uh often do i come here
i come here a bit
i'm here uh you know from time to time
do you go to school here yep
so i think i had a class with you oh
yeah what club
history maybe yes i think that's what it
was
you don't necessarily might not remember
me you know
i like it here it doesn't mean because i
go here i'm a genius i am
very smart hey how's it going how are
you good how are you doing you want it i
don't know
what class did you did you say that was
history
yeah just history it must have been a
survey course then
yeah it was it was surveys right you
should check it out so go to course it'd
be a good class
how'd you like that course you know
frankly
i found the class you know rather uh
elementary
elementary you know i don't doubt that
it was yeah i uh
i remember that class it was um it was
just between recess
and lunch clark why don't you go away
why don't you relax i must go away just
having fun with my new friend that's all
you gonna have a problem no no no no no
no there's no problem here
i was just hoping you might give me some
insight into the
evolution of the market economy in the
southern colonies
my contention is that uh prior to the
revolutionary war
the economic modalities especially in
the southern colonies
could most aptly be characterized as
agrarian pre-capitalism right of course
that's your thing
you're a first-year grad student you
just got finished reading some moxie and
historian
pete garrison probably you're gonna be
convinced of that until next month when
you get to james lemmon then you're
going to be talking about
how the economies of virginia and
pennsylvania were entrepreneurial and
capitalist way back in 1740. that's
going to last until next year you're
going to be in here regurgitating gordon
wood
talking about you know the
pre-revolutionary utopia and the capital
forming effects of military mobilization
well as a matter of fact i won't because
wood drastically underestimates the
impact
social justice underestimates the impact
of social distinctions
predicated upon wealth especially
inherited wealth
you got that from vickers work in essex
county page 98 right
yeah i read that too were you going to
plagiarize the whole thing for us do you
have any thoughts
of your own on this matter but is that
your thing you come into a bar you read
some obscure passage and then pretend
you pawn it off as your own
as your own idea just to impress some
girls embarrass my friend
see the sad thing about a guy like you
is in 50 years you're going to start
doing some thinking on your own and
you're gonna come up with the fact that
there are two certainties in life
one don't do that and two you dropped
150 grand on a [ __ ] education you
could have got for a dollar fifty in
late charges at the public library
yeah but i will have a degree and you'll
be serving my kids fries at a
drive-through on our way to a skiing
trip
yeah maybe yeah but at least i won't be
unoriginal
but i mean if you have a problem at that
i mean we could just step outside we
could figure it out
oh man there's no problem
it's cool it's cool yeah cool
[ __ ] damn right how you like
my boy's wicked smile